[Music]
i personally think there's a huge split
in this area between police and the
the local community
the first thought here would not be i'm
going to call the police i hold the f of
the police the police don't care and we
don't it's a long term problem it's
never going to be fixed overnight
tottenham north london
this place and its people have been
through a lot
one of the things that defines this area
is the tension between two very
different communities
the people who live here
and the metropolitan police they'll say
we're a hard community to reach and
we'll say the same back the other way i
think the generation seemingly unable to
forget the past i condemn the police
action breaking into an innocent woman's
house and causing her death so i've come
to tottenham because i want to find out
what it's like now for both sides
i spend half my time with the police
you're on a boardwalk
you know what happens down here it's
known for a lot of items and the other
half with the community they're
responsible for
i'm just a product of my own environment
i'm not a gang member
i'm a family member
[Music]
we are the violet suppression unit
we're specifically here to try and
target violent crime violent offenders
running towards us
five miles breaking off icy free all
dark clothing mud's got a uh a white
plastic jd bag dolphin
it's quite a dangerous place to please
like you generally don't come down here
unless you're in pretty good
numbers
we come on here six of us
and we come across like a group if the
group runs it's a nightmare you've got
flats all over the place roads
everywhere everybody back that way
jim
jeffery go back the way we came there's
one running towards
your phone
and police officers and run for no
reason okay which leads me to believe
you may be in the in possession of an
offensive weapon a knife
or some kind of other weapon okay
so based on that in fact you are
detained for a section one pace search
what am i going to find
when you are here doing stops you have
to be very careful with how you deal
with people
because you'll have
members of the community just coming out
from nowhere
why why do they surround you guys
it's just trying to intimidate us from
doing our job they think it's going to
stop us from doing our job
this suspect would search for weapons
and drugs but nothing's found and he's
released
it's all in your pockets let's look for
any black guys on the block people run
from us we assume they're up they've got
a reason to run from us so let's just
have a look honestly explain that to me
you're a bunch of animals you explain it
to me you said to me
the boardwater farm has a lot of good
stories but obviously linked to some of
the bad stories as well
the two facts that always come back are
keith blakelock and mark duggan
[Applause]
it was during an uprising here that a
police officer was murdered
i now appeal to all responsible citizens
to join
in identifying and bringing forward
those responsible for keith blake blocks
day
so they locked all of us black people in
there
don't you think that was going to build
a rage
and that rage was bubbling and bubbling
and it just exploded
[Music]
i was stigmatized by the police
where they came and kicked off my door
arrested me
um took me into the station for three
days terrorized me for the death of a
police officer i do not know about
all because i lived on baltimore to farm
and that's really that's what as well
has put the hate in me
things got worse for paulette when one
of her friends was killed by a police
officer
his name was mark duggan
i heard the shot from where i live
on the road where i live we all heard
the shot that killed mark duggar
tottenham erupted
and the rest of london followed
it was horrible it was very horrible
what happened after the ride we didn't
want this
i didn't want these things to happen
mark duggan's death affected smaller
children yeah it's not just the big ones
it's affected smaller children so those
small children now are growing up to
know that so they say that they were six
at the time when mark died they're now
16.
they've got
hate and no trust in the police
pretty much from when i can remember i
was interested in the police force
tried to get involved as much as i could
with local bobbies back then because
they did walk the b
when you're out playing football with
your mates they'd always come over and
talk
[Music]
i had a good impression of police when i
was a youngster
it's very different actually
the dream compared to the reality
right now
it's the worst it's been for police
officers especially in my career and i'd
say the hostility towards police is
more now than it ever has been
we're specifically here to try and
target violent crime violent offenders
um knife crime
um which also obviously comes a lot hand
in hand with um
with drugs or drug dealing and stuff
like that but our main job is to
suppress violence in harrington
and there's a lot of knives out there
on the streets of this borough
so if we if we get an inkling and
someone's got a weapon they're going to
get stop searched getting a knife out of
someone's pocket or out of a bag is
there's no better feeling than that
they're only
they're only carrying that knife for one
reason from my point of view the people
who are in the game in the gangs don't
really seem to have any care for
life or
what i would say the general public do
have but
they just don't care they don't they
don't respect us either so
it's quite difficult to manage
how do you feel that the wider community
greets you guys when you go into that
area i think around here most of the
time it's terribly
i personally think there's a huge split
in this area between police and the
local community
a lot of people
don't want to speak to us
i don't know if policing can do more to
improve that
i want to understand why the
relationship is that bad
i've come to meet a well-known community
activist who is a mentor for young
people here
many of them are involved in gangs
unfortunately
what i see of society
we're building
men strong body men
with weak minds
and that's a dangerous recipe for people
to lose their to lose control far
quicker
and if you've got the the added recipe
where we don't have
we've got little respect for law and
order
that means that we've got no faith in
the police to come and deal with
whatever violations has occurred to me
so i will take the law into my own hand
and take the retribution
any which way i feel so you think
there's just
if if just say a stabbing happens
around here you think that the first
thought in the majority of people's
minds here would not be i'm going to
call the police
absolutely why should i i'm not a snitch
because they would solve the crime i'm
not a stitch i'm not an informer but the
person behind bars i hold the f of the
police
i ask ken to put me in touch with
someone who can tell me what it's really
like to be so close to the violence
around here
he sends me to meet a young man who got
involved in what he called street life
as a teenager
he now wants to leave that world but
that is easier said than done
do you know anyone who's
been murdered
yeah i i got i buried three friends
sorry to hear that what happened to them
it was stabbed
you know what i'm saying so it's like
i've seen like my friends stiff in the
casket and obviously that has an effect
on you as as a as a young male but at
the same time it's woke me up because it
showed me there is no respawns in this
life and it's not a computer game bro
you get you get shot once you get
stabbed once you have no control over
where that bullet's tearing through you
have no control over where that that
that stainless steel or knife is tearing
through you have no control of that
always takes it's one and you're gone
was that the tipping point for you when
you you had to bury your friends yeah
that was that was that was that was the
time i said
this is this is dead man i need to get
out of here
[Music]
there's been a spate of knife point
robberies in the area
[Music]
from the main entrance spicy free mail
black clothing all hooded up
it was fun
it's gone north normally if it looks
wrong it is wrong
[Music]
so you're going to be getting searched
now for any weapons or you um
name me knives at least you just come
back on the strip side why are you not
doing this if you're detained for a
section one place my name is pc here are
you running partially well with that
okay reason being okay
a lot more people will carry weapons
there'd be a lot more assaults with
deadly weapons
whoa put my phone in my pocket
i don't know why you're talking to us
like that i can talk however i want it's
just rude in it i don't care
you know harassment every single day
okay how do you go after the bad guys
without alienating the good guys in
these communities
it's a difficult question
all i can say is from my own
experience and working with these guys
is
you you treat everybody with respect
you know even if it's a bad guy
you still treat that bad guy with
respect he's a human being at the end of
the day we're there to stop bad behavior
aren't we
whether that alienates
passes by
i
i don't think we can do anything about
that
london is on track for one of the worst
years for teenage murders in decades
many of the victims are children
and i'm reminded of this as i arrive at
broadwater farm
oh really how old was he succeeding
[Music]
the reason i've come back here is to
meet someone very well known in the
community
moses andy how are you doing
nice to meet you
and he's equally well known by the
police
how do you think the police would
describe you
as a minister society
and are you
a minister no
i'm a family man
we're portrayed
as criminals as gang members has any of
those people that portray us as that way
ever spoke to us and said to us how do
you feel as a person
you mentioned gang wars
gang wars in what way well i mean a
young kid's just been stabbed over there
hasn't he all right i don't really know
what that's about but i can tell you
there is a lot of people that don't like
us from other areas and that's how it
works so i could be out there just with
my wife or my child chilling
walking like it's happened five times
already walking my mom's been there me
and my mum wherever
what shot at yeah you've been shot at
yeah many times man
nothing really happens over it that
helps the community what's benefiting us
what is helping us we're still here
suffering there's nothing that helps us
get jobs there's nothing that helps us
elevate we're still stuck in the same
room
do you think there's an answer to this
problem or do you think this issue is
just going to go on and on and on
i think it's a long term problem it's
never going to be fixed overnight i
think we just always have to
keep working at it
i'll be honest with you there could be a
solution to it but i am not the person
to tell you because i don't know if this
is huge i might not even live
to see the solution
do you think that this situation is ever
going to get better no
no but we do need help the police do
need to come and help us
if we make a mistake we've got to hold
our hands up and say yeah we're sorry we
dealt with that wrong but how do we make
it better and how do we make that better
it's with the community's help we need
their help
you